the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion you ever talk to them the glazes
never never not since you've gone back
no they give all the power to the
president the sport directive
a lot of Manchester United fans
are very negative about the glazes they
think they're taking all the money out
and are spending enough on players on
the infrastructure issues he talked
about do you think the fans are right
the fans are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the players we want the best for the
club I want the best of the club this is
why you're coming to Manchester United
this is why I love this club
but you have some
things inside the club which is don't
help to Manchester reach the top level
as
City Liverpool and even now Arsenal for
example
which is complicated it's difficult
um
it's hard in my opinion it will be hard
for Manchester to be in the top of
the game
the next two three years one of your
biggest critics has been and I'm
surprised about this me too Wayne Rooney
for example who you played with for many
years very successfully and we're good
friends with him and yet all this year
three or four times he's come out and
attacked you in the media Pierce I don't
understand you should ask this question
to him but
I don't know
um I don't know why he criticized me so
bad or is it jealousy as well perhaps
that you're still playing and still in
there probably because he finished his
career with 30s so I'm still playing
higher level I'm not gonna say that I'm
looking better than him which is is true
but
but that is inarguable I mean there's no
contest is is hard to listen that kind
of criticize a negative about
people who we play with you for example
Gary Neville as well yes I mean Gary
never you blanked him the other day uh
on the pitch and he looked quite upset
actually
um because he obviously likes being your
friend but he's been pretty critical of
you as well people can have can have his
own opinion but they don't really know
what's going on for example inside the
the training ground and Carrington area
or even my life they should listen not
only one point of view they have to
listen my point of view as well because
it's easy to to criticize but if you
don't know the old story it's it's it's
easy you know but it's peace as I say
before it's it's part are they still
friends of yours or do you have a line
where they are not my friends do you
feel a bit betrayed when they do that
because you because you played together
it's easy it's easy to criticize I don't
know if you'd have
a job in television that they must
criticize
its way to be more famous I really don't
understand doesn't they use your name a
bit too I think they take advantage of
that because they are not stupid and I
really understand and I have to carry on
with my life with criticize criticize or
or
when the people speak good about you but
it's hard when you see people who was in
the dressing room with you criticizing
that way it must hurt it's not good yes
I do but not hardly I I'm not gonna be
more slim I'm not gonna sleep bad
because of the criticize but it's not
good to listen that disappointing
a little bit yes disappointing